Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to to be my new Witcher Netflixvideo about Ciri's power and what the special
prophecy that she was talking about in that
scene means it's called Ithlinne's prophecy
you may have heard people talk about it before, but if you're brand-new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the Witcher
videos I'll be doing bonus videos while we
wait for season to to get here because a lot
of you might be finding the show for the first
time I'll also do giveaways for the actual
games and the books so all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber and leave
your biggest theory about season two on the
video careful for spoilers for everything
from the Witcher Netflix season one is because
of this under this top 10 style.
I think I can do this in under 15 minutes.
It's complicated but I think is a simple way
to explain the prophecy starting with number
10 so during that scene on the show Ciri is
attacked by a group of her former subjects
that she used to play games with in the street dressed up like a commoner, so regular people
would recognize her as royalty.
She kicks and screams that they used to be
friends and in keeping with the themes of
the show.
Sometimes humans are the real monsters, not the typical monsters you would expect Geralt
to be hired to fight they don't let up in
then they are going to kill her and steal
her meager possessions in her horse which
she herself just stole a little while ago
and in this moment of extreme distress Ciri's, elder blood powers kick in instinctively and
she starts speaking the words of it liens
prophecy.
Ithlinne was this legendary Elven healer
a long time ago that first spoke of this prophecy
that Ciri is speaking during the scene.
The reason why Ciri is able to speak this prophecy without ever having heard it before herself
in her life or understanding what it means
is because of the elder blood in the power
she possesses Ciri is the unwitting product
of a centuries long plan enacted by the elves
to create a being that was capable of stopping Ithlinne's prophecy from coming true.
So number nine.
The elder blood you may have heard that term and not totally understood what it means if
you have them play the games or you haven't read the books a long time ago after hearing
Ithlinne's prophecy the elves started a special program to create a being that was so powerful
in magic that they be able to stop the prophecy.
So became this genealogical program tracking the gene as it was passed down from father
to son mother to daughter through generations.
But what happened is, is that one of the elves eventually made with a human in that pass
the gene to the humans and that's how Ciri
wound up with the special power.
Some people think it's a curse.
Some people think it's a blessing that gives
the users people like Ciri control over time
and space to be then the ability to travel
between worlds in the multiverse, so I bet
you didn't expect to find a lot of science
fiction inside this Witcher fantasy story,
but that sort of gets into the idea of the
conjunction of the spheres you may have heard
that term during the TV show all explained
that in the second to they gets into the more
sci-fi concepts in the more multi-reversal
level parts of the story.
There is a multiverse within the world of
the Witcher.
It explains were a lot of the really crazy
stuff comes from that you see during the course
of the show.
So, number eight Ciris prophecy on the show.
She speaks it in the scene she speaks a shorter version of the prophecy from the books, but
is the exact same it liens prophecy from the books.
The full version goes like this, verily I
say unto you, the air of the sword and the
axe is nigh, the era of the wolf's blizzard
the time of the white chill and the white
light is nigh, the time of madness.
and the time of contempt. the time of end, the world will die amidst frost and be reborn
with the new sun.
It will be reborn of elder blood of the seed
that has been sown a seed which will not sprout
but burst into flame.
Thus, it shall be watch for the signs what
signs shall be I say unto you first.
The earth will flow with the blood of elves
There's a whole bunch of stuff to unpack in that
but number seven the time of madness.
What they're talking about here is the conjunction of the spheres mentioned by Fringilla and
the brotherhood of sorcerers.
It speaks of a time when there will again
be another cataclysm on a multiverse scale
when the spheres the worlds from different
realities within the multi-verse come into
alignment.
So if you haven't read the Witcher books thousands of years ago before the events on the show
and in the books.
There was a conjunction of the spheres and different planets from the multi-verse crossed
over with each other, causing all kinds of
crazy monsters to get trapped on this main
world of the show is also when the elves say primordial humans first came to this world
from another reality elves of the original
inhabitants of the world.
They kind of get into that in the first couple
of episodes of the TV show humans actually
came from another world, and it's also as
they say during this cut scene from the games
when magic came to the world.
Since then humans have been misusing it for their own personal gain.
Obviously elves are trying to save the world
save their own culture.
That's why they started the elder blood program so number six when serious chanting about
the time of the sword and the acts being denied she just talking about the chaos that's going
to erupt.
The big war during the next conjunction or
call the next cataclysm when the next conjunction
of the spheres happens in the world the line again in the world as we know it.
The world were on right here becomes overrun with a thousandfold more monsters.
While Syria still the main part of this.
She's meant to stop this cataclysm from happening Geralt is also a big part of this to the
time of the sword and the acts being die because he is literally trained to fight the monsters
that will be crossing over into our reality.
The wild hunt is another good example that
like Geralt to is capable of fighting the
wild hunt.
Even though they're super powerful but they're also beings that come from outside of this
world.
So number five.
Next part of the prophecy when she talks about the wolf's blizzard in the time of the white
chill and the white light.
That's the part of ithlinne's prophecy that
speaks about the coming of the next Ice Age,
which according to the prophecy will come
in the next 3000 years covering the earth
in endless winter make all the game of thrones white walker long night jokes that you want.
There's something about these huge epic fantasy sagas and cyclical climate change parallels
Witcher book series started a little bit earlier in the 90s than a song of ice and fire it
just a coincidence.
They both have climate change parallels because the stories are about completely different
things.
Number four there's a special vision that
Ciri gets of the shining tree in the desert
when she drinks the waters of brokilon from Shaya Kayan the oldest tree in Brokilon
where all the special water flows from some of you probably figured out what this
means.
The vision is meant to be a metaphor for how everything that's going on in the story is
connected past present future.
The multiverse Ciri.
Her elder blood powers Geralt, Yennefer
Emperor Emhyr nilfgaard the tree represents
Yggdrasil the world tree which connects all the different worlds of the multi-verse,
and the characters the desert the sand represent the sands of time in the cyclical nature of
these cataclysms the conjunction of the spheres even though you thought this is going to be a
fantasy story about a Witcher hunting monsters there's a lot of science fiction going on
in this so number three the time of contempt as is described inside
the prophecy is also the title of the second
novel.
It's the fourth book, technically, that would
be the story that they adapt for season three
of the TV show that's a metaphor for the coming war in the fact that Geralt's not going to
be able to afford to have contempt for the
world itself.
The way that Yennefer showed a lot of contempt for the world in the TV show like during the
battle of sodden Hill.
She didn't really care that much about the
world but by the end of the fight.
She finally decides to participate in take
an active role in helping the world.
She unleashes her full power.
There's a line of dialogue from the book at
time of contempt the very beginning where
Geralt's talking to this lawyer and he says
what drives you if you want to save Ciri.
I wouldn't have thought you could afford the luxury of contempt know that was badly expressed,
you can afford the luxury of spurning contempt at time of contempt is approaching Witcher
my friend a time of great and utter contempt.
You have to adapt what I'm proposing is a
simple solution.
Someone will die.
So someone else can live someone you love will survive a girl you don't know and whom
you've never seen will die.
So just another reference to the coming war in the conjunction of the spheres.
The big cataclysm this coming number 2 what do all the symbols in the title sequence mean
because usually there's only one symbol for each of the titles, but in the finale you
have all these different symbols forming into the white wolf with the star in the swallow
so the solar eclipse represents the black
sun under which Renfri was born the prophecy
of the black sun, that all
these crazy people will be born that'll lead to the end of the world.
The obsidian star surrounded by eels represents Yennefer the symbol of her pendant and the
other initiates the conduits of Aretuza. Remember there were all those eels that were swimming
around in the fountain creating that magical power the clawed footprint with the Temerial
Lily represents the Striga princess
adda that Geralt save during the season.
The broken sword surrounded by the tree represents the tree from Ciri's dreams Yggdrasill the
world tree and the sword of destiny.
Remember that the title of the second book
in the metaphor that she and Geralt's destinies
are bound together because she's so important Geralt protect her.
The female in the male figures intertwined
represent guilt and Yennefer and the symbols
that she painted on her abdomen.
The symbol of her uterus.
The Dragon represents the Dragon that he saved during the season and its progeny, fun fact
too. Because the games are a sequel to the events of the books that Dragon eventually hatches
and shows up as a character during the video games.
The shattered lion represents the fall of
Cintra than the three final symbols that formed
together here represent Gerald Ciri in Yennefer symbols it's Gwynbleidd the white wolf Zireael
represents swallow. That's also
the name of the sword that Geralt eventually gets for Ciri later when she's an adult and
the obsidian star represents Yennefer. the
fact that they come together is a metaphor
for how Geralt and Yennefer and Ciri's destinies are now bound together so number one.
What does this all mean for the season to plot because season 2 is going to be based on
the book blood of elves.
The first main novel in the Witcher series,
but technically his third book, overall season 1
was mostly based in the first two books which are really just collections of short
stories meant to be prequels explaining who the characters are and how they came together
before they actually do come together in blood of elves, the title blood of elves.
Obviously, as you probably guessed, is a reference to Ciri's elder blood, but is also a metaphor
about what humans have done to eradicate most of the elves in the world and how Ciri is
supposed to be the promise one created to
save them all from this coming cataclysm will
probably get into how she deals with that
knowledge, when she starts to learn how special
she is because Ciri does know that she has
power but she does understand what it means
where it comes from and what Geralt is going to do once he learns who it is.
This coming after Ciri and trying to use her
power for their own personal gain.
So really when you think about it.
Ciri is actually the most important character in the Witcher story.
Even though most people come to this thinking think Geralt is the main character just because
you typically play as his character during
the video games and for a lot of people that's
really their only in, to this story.
Even though the books have gotten way more popular since the games started to blow up
so hopefully you do have the opportunity to
check the books out at some point. if you haven't,
read them they're fantastic. season 2 probably won't premiere till around summer 2021 maybe
later, hopefully won't be that late during
the year but I will do update videos about
production when they start actually shooting the season.
I'm sure there's a thousand more questions
that you guys have, Write them all below
in the comments if there are any big Easter eggs the spotted in the prophecy that I didn't
mention the video just write them below in
the comments while you wait for everything.
Click here for all my Witcher Netflix episode videos and click here for my new Mandalorian Season 2
video, that you so much for watching everybody stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!